so we we have this technique that other
people really haven't used but we found
to be very powerful technique and
because they've been looking at the fate
of the oxygens of inorganic phosphate
when it made ATP those oxygen one of
them goes to make water hmm
now we found that by use of the stable
isotope oxygen-18 we could measure this
reaction and water going in and out of
phosphate part of the process and by
measure that under the conditions we can
probe down as what's happening in the
heart of the enzyme that we couldn't see
by other way oh yeah
so we had a way or safe way of seeing
what's happening down inside and really
the start of the binding change
mechanism was when I was sitting in a
seminar talking about some aspects of
theoretical chemistry that I did not
understand yet and so I let my mind walk
and then I suddenly came to me that
stage but a few times I get a stroke of
insight I can explain our oxygen-18 data
if the energy is not used to make the
ATP molecule but if it can be made
without the energy input when the energy
is used to release our ntp mallya so
that was the startup and that was the
sudden inspiration ever so that's one
time
there was a starting point now and other
times you make progress you you can
hardly recognize you started none this
was a start down it yeah